(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
I appreciate that.
Thank you very much. I...
(CHUCKLES) I don't even--
-WOMAN: We love you, Bill!
-I know.
-We're in it together, right?
-(AUDIENCE SHOUTING)
That's the important thing.
We're in this together, 'cause--
I mean, even by normal
Trump weeks, this was...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-I mean...
So much crazy shit happened,
I'm just going to have to go
through it chronologically.
First off, you heard Hope Hicks
was voted off the island.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
And, you know, Hope Hicks,
this was Trump's,
you know, his work wife,
his emotional companion animal.
-Whatever she did there, and--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
This has really thrown him off,
because she was one of the few
people he could work with,
they were a very good team,
she was a former model,
and everything he says makes
you want to throw up. So--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-(BILL LAUGHS)
-And it's-- It's very...
-(APPLAUSE)
It's very ironic because he was
very dependent on Hope Hicks,
and his whole presidency
is about giving hicks hope.
-So it was--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-He's-- But listen...
-(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
She is 29 years old.
Twenty-nine.
The communications director for
the president...
of the United States...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...of America.
A communications director,
by the way,
that no one in America
has ever heard speak.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
In Fire and Fury,
he says her main job
during the campaign was steaming
Trump's husky boy sack suit...
while it was on him.
She would sit in a chair
in front of him
and blow dry his crotch.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Also, on her resume...
-(BILL LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...she used to date
Corey Lewandowski,
who was Trump's campaign manager
and married at the time.
Then she dated Rob Porter,
who had to leave the White House
earlier in the month,
in a wife-beating scandal.
Uh-- You know, I'm not
that familiar with soap operas,
but I think in the next episode,
um...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...Trump gets amnesia, and...
Mike Pence reveals
he's a woman.
I think that's what happened.
(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
Okay, so...
(APPLAUSE)
Anyway, she's gone.
Off to "pursue"
other opportunities.
Yes, she feels she can be
much more effective
steaming the pants of--
(LAUGHS)
...creepy old men
in the private sector.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-You can't write this.
So, now the prettiest deaf mute
in the West Wing is Jared.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
And...
Oh, yes, in other news from
the Lancaster clan--
I mean, the Lannister clan.
Shit. I should have gotten
the HBO joke right, shouldn't I?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-Uh...
The knives are really out
for Jared Kushner. He lost
his top security clearance,
there's an Archie Bunker,
Meathead thing going on
with General Kelly,
and, oh, it turns out
that every inexplicable
fucked-up thing
that's happened in the last year
is really because Jared's
trying to get
$1.2 billion dollars
to pay for a building
he shouldn't have bought.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
He-- Really!
This is all making sense now.
He had meetings with two banks
in the White House,
who gave him
500 million dollars,
and his security clearance has
over a hundred omissions
and errors on it.
I can say this because
my mother was Jewish,
he's too stupid to be a Jew.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-Really-- I...
(APPLAUSE)
I wanna see his birth
certificate! I do-- I...
I think it's gonna say
"Birthplace: Alaska.
Real name: Jared Palin."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-(APPLAUSE)
-So...
No, he is an Orthodox Jew
and they're already setting up
a prison for him: Unleavenworth.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
But, uh... (LAUGHS)
But I love this.
Sources say that Trump...
is siding with General Kelly...
to try to get General Kelly
to help get
Jared and Ivanka out of
the White House.
Finally, a Trump issue that real
Americans can relate to:
Not being able to get your
grown kids out of the house.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-(APPLAUSE)
-And, so-- Okay.
Hope Hicks is gone,
Rob Porter is gone,
they say McMaster,
the national security adviser,
one of the adults,
he's got only a few weeks left,
maybe Gary Cohn, the treasurers.
Who is going to be left?
Trump's going to be all alone
in the White House
talking to a soccer ball
with a face painted on it.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
This...
And, you know, all this chaos
makes it very difficult
for the NRA to run the country.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Oh, and they do!
(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
I think we saw that this week.
Oh, did you see Trump at
the White House
with that bi-partisan meeting
when he...
freaked out Republicans
when he suggested raising
the gun age from 18 to 21
and seizing the guns
of people who posed a threat?
He said,
this is his actual words,
from Donald Trump, President,
"I like taking the guns early.
Take the guns first,
go through due process second."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
That's right, Republicans.
Turns out there is a President
who'll ignore the Constitution,
who'll come for your guns.
The one you fucking idiots
voted for!
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
All right.
All right, kids.
-Ear muffs, kids.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
(CHUCKLES) Kidding!
Uh-- But of all the most,
I must say, galling things...
that I've ever heard him say,
maybe the most revolting, you
heard what he said this week?
"I really believe
I'd have run in there...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...even if I didn't have
a weapon."
Of course, he was talking about
the dressing room
at the Miss Teen USA pageant,
but--
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
(CHUCKLES)
Well, things are changing.
You know how?
Corporate America,
Dick's Sporting Goods
is no longer selling AR-15s.
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
That show's how much
this debate has shifted, huh?
When a company says, "We're not
selling assault weapons
and we're dicks."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)